the US Army Corps of Engineers is
preparing to convert the Miami Beach
Convention Center into a medical
facility to help assist in the sea v19
response Ainsley currently Florida has
more than 14,000 700 confirmed cases and
health officials expect the peak to hit
that state at the beginning of May yep
so joining us right now from Miami
Florida Senator Marco Rubio senator I
want to talk to you about this rescue
plan because you focused on small
business while were you the chairman of
the subcommittee there but I first want
to get to your sense of Florida
I saw those huge lines when it come to
food banks how is the people of Florida
responding to the lockdown well I want
to say the people of Florida have
responded well in terms of following the
mandate so obviously there are people
that try to get around and people that
have to you know it's interesting you
know if you work in a blue-collar job
you're probably out there having to work
right now whether you work at the
grocery store or CVS Walgreens or at
some other place that's been deemed
essential and of course all the people
first responders and so forth but by and
large you've seen that Florida has
outperformed all of the models it's not
because the models were wrong it's
because we are but we are doing our part
and we're going to keep an eye on that
and I also think our local hospitals
across the state have done a great job
of sort of building up capacity and
getting ready to address whatever comes
our way that's right and I know that in
the Senate there's already some talk
about another phase some of the points
from the Democrats nixed relief bill
would be a quarter of a trillion dollars
in assistance to small businesses one
hundred billion dollars for hospitals
community health centers and health
systems 150 billion dollars for state
and local governments and a 15 percent
increase to the minimum snap benefit
among other things and one interesting
thing that Senator Chuck Schumer
suggested senator is for up to $25,000
hero pay essentially for the people on
the frontlines whether they are nurses
or truckers or grocery store clerks
somehow the government compensating them
for
essentially putting their lives at risk
every day when they go to work what do
you think of that idea
well the way I think we should
approaches is we can did to bifurcate
this into two pieces the first is sort
of what do we need to do to build on
what we've already passed so for example
the Small Business Fund despite some
early glitches is already at sixty six
billion dollars I've already been
committed so it's moving very quickly
there's tremendous demand so that's why
there's gonna be an effort tomorrow to
try to come in and add some funds to
that so building on what we've done
adding to what we've already done in
past a second is a recovery bill there's
a relief and then there's recovery and I
think for recovery some of them are
deeper more systemic reforms we want to
see things like our support paint duster
capacity in the country on industries
that are essential and then maybe some
of the things that you've mentioned
looked at I these people that are out
there every day that are delivering
goods we've had a run on paper towels
not just tore the paper paper towels and
so those truckers that are making those
long hauls overnight to get not just
paper towels but food and things like
that into our grocery stores not to
mention our doctor the nurses are doing
a phenomenal job on the front line I'm
all for doing positive things to help
them after this very difficult
circumstance I think that of course is
going to require a little bit more
thought and maybe being able to bring
Congress together to work through it so
I'm not saying no to any of these things
I'm just saying that those things are
new and will require some more thought
and it's hard to do that right now
because we're not in session we don't
know when we will be yeah senator the
president is slamming the World Health
Organization I'm sure you know that then
he says they've been routinely wrong he
said they were strongly against the
travel ban back in January they're
saying he says that everything is
positive toward China they're not giving
us the right information and that the
u.s. is the primary funder of that
organization we give the most money but
yet we don't get the most help he says
so he's talking about cutting funding
Lindsey Graham says he's definitely
going to do that what do you say well
couple things on the World Health
Organization let's remember that on the
front lines they have people all over
the world they're doing a phenomenal job
in terms of epidemiologists they're
doing research and so forth our problems
with a leadership because the World
Health Organization serves an important
purpose on
it has been politicized China has
undertaken an effort over the last 15
years to sort of infiltrate and and
exert influence over international
organizations at the UN and of course
the World Health Organization now what
you saw early on in this pandemic as
they went to China and came out saying
there china is doing a great job
everything they're saying is true and
then condemning like not just the US but
also condemning any country that
considered bans on travel from or to
China
and there's evidence of political but
it's been politicized that the World
Health Organization at its leadership
level was politicized by Chinese
influence and Chinese money and that's
unfortunate because that organization
should not be political and should not
make me making public health
pronouncements under duress brought from
any country in the world it should be
making those pronouncements on the basis
of medical science and so I have deep
concerns about it and that's why you
know I hope that at a minimum we can get
the leader of that organization to
resign because he's definitely been
politicized senator every time I get
shot every sentence over the last few
weeks with unprecedented one of which
was the 2.2 trillion dollar plan to keep
people in their jobs and businesses that
aren't working funded so part of the
plan that you helped put together on
small business in some cases is not
functioning yet number one is when these
people come in if they can't get retain
their workforce at 75% they won't be
eligible to make that loan a grant and
if their people don't come back it's out
of there it's out of their control and
number two is when you're done paying
for your payroll you don't have enough
money to pay for your lease and your
rent so would you be revisiting some of
that for these higher priced cities like
Los Angeles in New York and maybe even
Miami yeah potentially but not right now
what we need to do is more funds just to
be able to get them out the door because
there's been a very strong demand for it
look a couple points to make number one
yes I think I fully understand that
people out there are desperate and want
this to work so do I I also think we
have to have some perspective this is a
plan that was passed two weeks ago this
Friday at him in two weeks yeah it was
implemented six days later there was
until Friday of this week there wasn't a
bank in America that
made a PPP loan and there wasn't they in
the SBA had never made one sysm rush out
in six days because we are in an
emergency when you have an emergency
situation it's chaotic I know that from
living through multiple hurricanes
you're managing the chaos at the same
time as you're trying to get rid of the
glitches that appear and everyday this
program has gotten better there are
still some substantial obstacles in the
way that need to be fixed this can't be
the way the program works long-term as
far as the payroll is concerned the
point of the program that's why it's
called the Paycheck Protection Act is to
get money into the hands of small
business so they can continue to pay
their employees even if the business is
not opening and running and there is a
portion of it that they can spend on
rent but we wanted the bulk of that
money to be to make payroll so we can
keep people off the unemployment lines
and keep them from disconnecting from
their employer the government can't
replace all the revenue of these
businesses and we never claimed it would
but we do think helping keep some
employees on payroll is a big assistance
and you can't spend a percentage of it
now if you can't hire all the people
back or whatever there are elements of
this at the back end a year from now
where you can show that I couldn't hire
my people back because they had left or
because of some other impediment and and
you can have that mitigated and forgiven
but but right now that the goal is to
keep people employed and put money in
the hands of workers that was always the
goal that was agreed to and a bipartisan
basis it's not perfect it certainly
doesn't deal with every issue but it
deals with a big one
sure senator Rubio before you go you
know we've all been locked down for a
couple of weeks now we try to save the
day of the week as often as we can
because all the days are kind of
blending into each other we saw the news
this morning that apparently your
colleague Rand Paul is he's fully
recovered from kovin and now he is
volunteering at his local hospital
because he is a doctor just out of
curiosity in your case what is a sitting
member of the US Senate do during a
lockdown what's your day like well up
first of all let me take theoretically
both Rand Paul and my friend Mario
diaz-balart a congressman here who was
also infected theoretically anyways the
assumption is that they have some
immunity that because they've acquired
the virus so that's
I don't want to go through what they've
gone through especially Mario but so
that's a benefit for them and it's
something we should think about in terms
of that new test that's coming on board
to show that people have sufficient anti
bought antibodies that to be but our
basic day starts early with some media
hits and then I spend all day probably 8
to 10 hours a day either doing a series
of conference calls or webinars with
different groups in Florida across the
country yesterday I talked to the
Florida bankers the National Bankers
Association and then a lot of phone
calls with folks in the administration
I'll be speaking to the FDIC today about
the program secretary minutiae has been
phenomenal and accessible and very
responsive so really the focus of my day
has been largely on the program and
getting it to work identifying the
impediments and trying to do as much as
we can here from home using the phone
using this computer and then
communicating to the public as well so
that that's been the gist of our
existence here since we got back from
from DC and there's a lot of work to be
done and then trying to stay safe you
know trying to model the behavior that
we're asking others to follow whether
it's wearing a mask in public I don't
look good in a mask but I have one here
that we made and so I've been using that
and and oral and also you know staying
at home as much as possible and working
from here as much as possible so I've
been quite busy actually but I think we
all like to see life get back to normal
as soon as possible but we got to get
through this we would we would thank you
so much senator